good afternoon everybody
and welcome
uh we're
a couple of minutes behind but this is a
fairly informal
uh gathering it would seem
we're here to discuss uh hb 1061
uh relative to
midwifery council
and
i'm going to take a moment well before i
even start i want to please remind you
that even though it's an informal thing
it is streaming and so when you step up
to speak please do make sure that your
microphone is turned on
let me go over a little bit of the
history of this because we've seen a lot
of bills
and uh some of us could use the reminder
although some who this is most close to
may not
um
let's see this uh this bill first had a
public hearing
on
january 20th of this year
and then
it went into a subcommittee meeting on
march 1st
followed by an executive session on
march 7th during which an amendment was
proposed and passed 18 to 1
and amongst the other things that that
amendment did it
it
reinstated midwives as a majority on the
uh on the board
it went uh for a vote ought to pass as
amended
and that vote failed by a vote of 8 to
and then the motion was made to send it
to interim study
that motion passed 19 to zero
and that's what brings us here
today it was placed on the consent
calendar passed in the house
so i'm going to um
just uh
and
this may be a little bit uh different
than some of the interim study
subcommittees you've attended because
this is the first one that i've chaired
but i'm going to try to cover all the
territory as briefly as possible
first i want to just give a brief
summary of the testimony that was
provided
in the public hearing
and then i'd like to give an opportunity
for anybody
who has an interest in this bill whether
on the committee or in the public to
speak
to summarize briefly the um
the public
testimony
for the bill was
all in opposition
and um
that's just a fact we had heidi
reinhardt who was an obgyn from keene
sherry stevens
chair
of a variety of others
the
proponents of the bill were the
committee members the co-sponsors and
they spoke and
made their support for the bill clear
they'll probably hear some more of that
today especially since we're speaking
about the amended
um version
my recollection is that there were two
major concerns about the bill
one was that it
converted the board from a
decision-making body
to an advisory body
and the second was that
from a majority of midwives on the board
it went to a minority of midwives
one ob gyn one pediatrician
i don't recall if it was one or two
midwives and perhaps a public member
anybody's uh please feel free to correct
me on that
two thank you
so would you
repeat the um
it increased the number of ob gyns which
was very uh threatening to the midwives
and uh not at all the intent of the
original sponsors but that was the way
the wording came out so that that was
something you're going to have more ob
gyns and midwives on the board that was
completely unacceptable to the
profession and frankly to myself as one
of the co-sponsors as well thank you mr
chairman thank you all right
the amendment which was um
put together by representative pearson
remedy that situation
and let me see if i can
quickly find
the new makeup of the board proposed in
the amendment
one obstetrician one pediatrician
three midwives
and if i recall there was some
discussion of a public member
but
perhaps there's someone in here who
knows best and can
correct me on that
yes
that amendment is
not ex was not actually adopted the
final vote was not to pass it with the
amendment but to go to interim study so
we do not need to consider the amendment
okay you want to yeah no thank you i i
um
i was unclear on that from the notes to
tell you the truth in the sequence i got
the sequence one out of step
but officially the vote to
interim study kind of wipes out the
amendment yes that's correct thank you
because um on the docket it does not
make mention of the amendment so we
discussed the amendment
but we did not pass it
and then we voted
18 to 1 or 19 to 0 to
to move it to interim study
at this time
i guess i would like to ask anyone who's
interested in speaking on behalf or an
opposition
to the bill
and to make a recommendation about what
might be done i would be pleased to hear
it now so if anybody would like to step
forward you're welcome to now
thank you don't forget the microphone
and please state your name in your
official capacity for the clerk i'm
sherry stevens and i am
the chair of the new hampshire midwifery
council
and um
so
i can i think this was um
oh sorry
i think this was um distributed to the
members before but it wasn't read
this is the official um
um letter from the council
so it's um my name is sherry stevens i
am a chairperson of the midwifery
council and i'm writing on the council
behalf the midwifery council is opposed
to hb 1061 because it fails to address
fundamental
better was on
this bill seeks to make the midwifery
council simply an advisory committee to
the executive director of the office of
professional licensure and certification
as advisory committee we would
have no independent ability to make
changes instead all actions would be
initiated and decided by the oplc
executive director
the midwifery council has worked to
cultivate a fundamental working
relationship with oplc staff and
administration
however we can cannot be guaranteed the
agency will continue to be cordial and
collap collaborative in the future under
different leadership
if this bill becomes law the midwifery
council would lose its ability to remain
the clinical experts who conduct
administrative rulemaking draft and
proctor examinations that is actually
changing now
and initiate investigations in imposed
discipline
the
midwifery council consists of a licensed
obstetrician a licensed pediatrician
three midwives and a member of the
public that's what it currently is
it is improper for the legislature to
give the oplc executive director
regulatory authority over the practice
of midwifery in new hampshire with
discretionary power to discard disregard
the expertise of experienced midwives
and physicians knowledge about midwifery
practice or profession
in order to preserve professional
midwifery autonomy the midwifery council
and to achieve the goals of functioning
within legal barriers we would endorse
amending the language of this proposed
legislation to reflect that the
midwifery council continued to act
autonomously with consultation of the
executive director of oplc
we respectfully request that you reject
hb 1061 or in the very least amend the
bill to charge experienced midwifery
professionals with input from
physicians who are knowledgeable in in
midwifery to make critical decisions
regarding the practice of midwifery in
new hampshire the midwifery council
welcomes the guidance and oversight of
oplc executive director to remain within
legal bounds in prudent administrative
practices thank you for your
consideration currently the
board makeup has three midwives an
obstetrician and pediatrician that have
experience working with midwifery
practices and a
member of the public and the um
sorry i'm thinking my words the
amendment had taken out the member of
the public but we think they're valuable
right so it kept it at five members
instead of booming it to six right um
which was a um
a matter of um
balance and i'm you know we were okay
with that we're that if that were to
come about
but we're very concerned with you know
losing the autonomy of
the mid referee profession as it is and
we
understand oplc's
reasoning that they had given
about wanting oversight and so we would
be happy to work with them and see if we
can't come to some kind of
way of making oversight um other than
completely losing our autonomy of our
profession
are there any questions from the
committee members for uh
ms stevens
yes
thank you mr chair uh i was concerned
that there aren't a lot of midwives in
new hampshire
and that in order to maintain autonomous
you'd have to charge
excessive fees
have you has the
council considered what kind of
technical and professional support they
need to arrange to pay for
it has not come to our um
attention in terms of
fees or our licensure we had had in the
past 200
was our fee for licensing um every two
years that we had
um
we had the ability to to make our fees
at that time and i believe that oplc has
changed that and our laws i mean our the
fee got changed to 110
quite honestly without our knowledge at
the time and
um
that they have the ability to to change
those fees on us at this point
but we have not had that discussion and
that has not been brought to my
attention
any other questions
yes and i i noticed that you're
in rule making on the scope of practice
how's that going it's going great we are
that's um
because they sunset they go out of date
that we look at them and make changes
and the scope of practice
we need to update certain things that
you know as time goes on they need to be
addressed but it's pretty it's not very
substantial
so our substantive
the the protocols that we're looking to
change at this time
it's more about getting them before they
expire
other questions
if not um then
yes representative
thank you mr chair i i was waiting to
see whether any of the other
representatives wanted to weigh in on
this because uh
as ms stevens knows from a long
conversation she and i had early days on
this when this bill was in the process
of
being brought forward
that our purpose
in fighting was not
to handcuff the midwives with regard to
their autonomy
and i did apologize i believe during the
course of the hearing with regard to
that that the language of the
of the bill as it landed on the on the
committee's doorstep
included several aspects which were not
uh were not uh certainly not my
intention
and i was not supportive of them
certainly
but
one of the issues
is that we have been trying to
um
to change the oplc
structure if you will
to
um
to be more
successful
and
and to be
more effective
and we started with a couple of the
smaller
professions so that we wouldn't tackle
some big profession it's kind of like
when your
child starts with a small bicycle before
a tricycle before they try a big bicycle
and they are big enough for that so
one of the problems has been that that
with some of the smaller boards
getting a quorum
when you have a small contingent of
practitioners
um
and
um and and the advisory aspect uh as
as it's
been put forward
the intent is to have the
administrative
function in the hands of
an oversight in the hands of the oplc
which is their forte they have attorneys
rules writers and so forth and so on
the practitioners should be in charge of
the scope of practice and all aspects
involving that
and the word advisory
is causing lots of complications because
it certainly implied to you and to many
of your practitioners the idea that you
were going to be
only
offering advice and the
executive director would have plenary
authority to do everything
and somehow
can you see a
a way or a word
that would
express the partnership of the two
entities oplc on the one hand
administratively
legally and so forth
the the in your case the midwives uh and
their medical
cohorts the ob gyns and pediatricians
would be on the side of
the science of midwifery
and that and neither side would have
dominance over the other each would
which
provide its area of expertise so that
the whole operation would be more
effective
in
advancing the cause in this case
of midwifery so
if if we can come to some kind of terms
that will that will
make that clear in the statute
and a future executive director could
not
take away your autonomy uh would you
more be inclined to
this
cooperative
arrangement than you you were initially
i think you and i understood each other
after our conversation certainly the
midwives and supporters of midwifery who
came to the bill
were not of they did not understand that
and they were not supportive of anything
other than the midwives being in charge
even if it was not maybe working as well
as it should on behalf of midwifery and
the right of citizens of new hampshire
to to go to midwives as opposed to being
seen in hospitals by ob gyn
representative i would like to hear the
answer to that thank you i appreciate
your indulgence mr chairman okay
um well first of all the
this bill as it is right now i think
what was said earlier was that the
amendment to change the balance of three
obs and midwives is still on the table
because
okay so that's this bill is
this bill is not in its in any form on
the table okay we're here to consider
using the this is a framework whether we
need
legislation for next year and if so what
would it consist of okay
so the i guess the question would be if
the um
if a new bill
um reflected the amendment
uh what would your your thoughts and
position be on that right
so officially what i can say that i have
we have a vote on from the council is
that we had wanted
to
this bill to um
be rejected and that if they oplc wanted
to have more
oversight over us that we would the
midwifery council continues to act
autonomously with consultation of the
executive director of oplc so if we were
to make decisions with our rulemaking or
make decisions with
our investigations things like that that
we would have to go to the executive
director and and it would put us in the
position of they could say yay or nay to
us and so we would still be
accountable to somebody other than our
group in terms of having quorum and
things like that there are enough
midwives in the state that meet the
requirements for
serving on the board and at this point
it's a little bit of
of a process to get somebody on a board
but we've had we've been able to fill
those positions we have the
um
public member is um
at large right now because we weren't
really
trying to fill that position because
this all was going on i think there are
people
um looking to just to fill that position
at this point but we've not had a quorum
issue and there's enough new midwives
coming in to the state and old midwives
like me that are going to be um done
with our service soon and there's enough
coming in so keeping a quorum of the
three midwives and the and the two
doctors and the public is is fine with
us and in terms of working with oplc
we are happy to i mean in right it costs
some money and we understand that but
have you know we were told that oplc is
coming in and we're going to help you
administratively we've had um members of
the oplc in our meetings that have kept
our meeting minutes going correctly and
everybody you know moving along with our
agendas and we welcome that we've been
very happy with that having legal
counsel in on the rulemaking and um when
we have investigations they have a
you know a process there that we are
doing our best to you know participate
in and and cooperate with we welcome
that that kind of help because you're
right we're not
rule-making authorities we are midwives
but when it comes to taking the autonomy
away from our
profession um the history is like dr
reinhart had said in her testimony that
this their profession
was actively um trying to wipe out
midwives and that's still true in this
country so new hampshire's wonderful new
hampshire's had this law um for 34 years
in new hampshire where we've certified
midwives but
one of the other
people talked about louisiana they had a
board just like this and they moved it
to advisory and then it's wiped out and
they're gone they don't have um
and we think that the the rules that we
go under our law and in our um
you know the midwifery rules that keep
us you know our scope of practice keeps
the public safe i mean if we didn't have
that there would be midwives as they
were prior to having this um rsa 326d
that made midwifery legal in new
hampshire they had midwives going and
doing twins and they had midwives doing
whatever they wanted and they're
certainly true in our neighbors into the
south of massachusetts they don't have
anything on their books and those kinds
of births of happening and i'm not
saying they're safe or unsafe that's not
for me to say but that's what was
happening in new hampshire we got our
326d we've made our rules what we
thought was keeping mid re as a
profession and the public safe by doing
that and we are accountable um
as midwives to follow into that protocol
and if we don't follow those protocols
we get disciplined right so that's what
we are doing to keep the public safe and
by certifying people which is the
process that we do which oplc now helps
us with which is wonderful and by
doing our rules keeping our rules that
were put in place and just updating them
as needed which is pretty minimal and
then by doing the discipline which oplc
also has taken over and has helped us
with and given us more legitimacy if we
had no
you know subpoena records oplc does that
which is better than me in my office
doing that right we want that kind of
legitimacy so we are really happy to
work with them but there's not another
profession
that i mean okay that's not right there
are possibly other professions that are
small boards that being an advisory
committee would be absolutely wonderful
and that's just what they need and that
that's all the support they need the
nursing board the medical board
they wouldn't do that to them they're
not going to do that to them they don't
have an intention to do that to them
midwifery is a small profession but what
we do is really important in our and our
being able to have autonomy over that
and say over that instead of just being
an advisory
position is extremely important to us as
a profession and our clients all right
thank you are there any further
questions
from stevens
representative
thank you mr chair
i will say that
at one of our committee of conference
meetings
the chair of our sister committee in the
senate
suggested that
she would like to see
to enable
a lot of these boards to meet
either remotely or hybrid
with your knowledge of the membership
of your profession do you feel that
would enable you to
better obtain quorums and and have
robust meetings absolutely um the ob
currently travels all the way from keene
which is a lot for her to do and take
out of her time in her practice and a
lot of us are on call so if i'm able to
stay in my office and have a meeting as
opposed to coming all the way down here
now i'm an hour and a half from my
client it would be much easier for us to
meet and we would have much more success
having quorum
follow-up just follow-up um
and i believe if i recall correctly
many of your members practice in the
north country is that true
no i'm the norm i'm in north um the
other two midwives on the council live
in concord
and the pediatrician lives in concord so
it's been
it's been fine for them but we in the
past we've yeah we're all over the state
where we live
thank you
any further questions
representative
thank you mr chairman
so i want to emphasize the point that
representative mcguire the edna chair
made earlier that the bill
and the amendment are both dead
our only function is to make a
recommendation which is not binding on
anybody
make a recommendation either to
to
recommend
further legislation on the subject
or to recommend no further legislation
but i as a representative and my
colleagues anyone else in the house is
free to file a bill
on anything
relevant to this subject so while the
present bill is is effectively dead
don't have to worry about that
we are still open to
offering further legislation so i am
seeking uh to find
some
framework that will promote
and support
um and maintain and care for
the practice of midwifery even though my
daughter was born in the hospital i
think i was born i know i was born in
the hospital although i have a question
please i yeah i'm getting there mr
chairman um so
i i'm very supportive
but i think this is something that i
would recommend that we work on further
to make sure that we're promoting
is this something you would be open to
it sounds like you are yes absolutely um
i have honestly not sat down with um
you know lindsay and and said what do we
need to do or what can we do um i'm open
to that conversation of i understand her
concerns of of
um oversight and so i'm open to that
discussion of what we can do to to
you know leave that problem as well so
yes i would be willing to do that um i
think that as it's been working
as oplc has been growing and changing
and and organizing and we welcome their
changes that they're making that's
wonderful and as our board has been
growing and changing and learning um
what we have right now could work really
fine if we need to do something else for
some further protection that's a
conversation we'd be happy to have okay
uh unless there's another question
that's uh unique i don't think we're
covering new ground
at this point so
i would uh like thank you for your
testimony and is there anybody else who
would like to speak
it's courtney
good afternoon
i'm lindsay courtney i'm the executive
director of the office um
and at first i wish to thank sherry for
for coming here for being involved
for willingness to work on i think what
is a difficult topic um
and i also wish to express that
that the concerns that we have generally
in the office are not necessarily
specific to the midwifery council
so
what i've observed um is that well first
off
professions and i think this is somewhat
controversial notion in the state of new
hampshire but it shouldn't be
professions are not entitled to regulate
their own profession that is something
that the legislature
makes a decision as to what the
framework should be for regulating a
particular profession whether
a profession should be regulated at all
and certain states have taken different
approaches
our approach has historically been
allowing active market professionals to
actively
um
regulate their own profession there are
some really good things about that and
there are some really not so great
things about that and i think that some
of the concerns that oplc has
centers around that structure that new
hampshire has chosen
um ultimately it's not up to me
obviously to make a decision about
whether there should be changes but i do
think it's it's
incumbent upon me to bring these
concerns to the legislature's attention
which is why we sought
support to file legislation to move some
boards to advisory
there is a concern about oversight um
namely because professionals are
professionals in their field midwives
are midwives doctors are doctors they
are not and they shouldn't be reasonably
expected to be experts in administrative
law in statutory compliance and
regulatory compliance
as a state i think we've grown
significantly
more complex from a legal standpoint
um it's no longer that you just look at
your practice act and
okay it tells you how to you know what
you need to comply with in order to meet
the statutory framework there are other
statutes that come into play statutes
that you need to know about and i
wouldn't reasonably expect a
professional to know for example 541a
applies 91a applies oh i need to look at
the statutes regarding labor because
there's a committee that needs to be
established or 21g applies these are
things that we expect our committees and
our boards councils and commissions to
know and actually in order to actually
comply with the statutes and rules that
we have in place but it's not reasonable
for us to expect them to do that
which is why i think the office was
created i think the office was created
obviously to provide that sort of
administrative support to make to make
sure that
boards councils and commissions have the
information they need to comply
but what we've found is there's no
mechanism for us to actually ensure they
are complying with the law so we can
provide you can you know you can lead a
horse to water but you can't force it to
drink that sort of thing and we run into
issues
um we've and you will you will you will
see another lba audit uh coming out and
it will highlight a lot of issues
and there have been many audits of
boards in the past highlighted a lot of
issues and it all centers around the
fact that this is not this is a
volunteer job for them this is something
they come in once a month once every
quarter to do
and so i think that with this model what
we get is
60 compliance with the law
there's no mechanism to provide
oversight
so that's really the basis for um
for seeking some sort of structural
changes
but there are more that you know there
is more than one way to skin the cat so
to speak
and this uh what was proposed in 1061
doesn't need to be the way
but they're in in my opinion there needs
to be oversight of these ports and it's
not just midwifery council
the supreme court for example in north
carolina dental made it very clear that
when you have active market participants
regulating their profession
there is an inherent risk that does play
out
that regulations will be put in place to
keep people out and not to protect the
public
and that is the purpose of licensing is
to protect the public it's not to
promote the profession and i think that
there's often um
a misunderstanding um
among many stakeholders about that
so i do think further legislation is
needed i don't know that it needs to
take the form of 1061 i think other
states have taken different approaches
um safety for example sherry uh ms
stevens had mentioned a consultation
requirement
safety when it had the mechanical board
had a requirement that all regulations
had to be approved by the commissioner
that sort of veto power
provided that state supervision
there are other states that have
different models
i do think it's very important that
professionals
have
input and
some decision-making power into criteria
and scope of practice
but i think that you really need to
combine
both state supervision experience with
administrative law and procedure
as well as individuals who have
that expert
knowledge in order to be successful at
regulating a particular profession
so with that um i'd be happy to answer
any questions
do committee members have a question for
miss courtney
representative
sorry carol you're in my
thank you um
okay
um i was going to ask about
administrative rules is that what you
were going to ask about no okay ms
stevens indicated that she's been
discussing that
with her committee or her counsel and
with you
do you agree with what she said that you
can work with her to
establish the priorities in
administrative rules that will help this
division that you're speaking of
yeah i think absolutely we can consult
with the council
and we're more than happy to do that
um
regarding yeah i mean yeah absolutely
representative mcguire
yes thank you i was actually going to
ask about uh
the the the fees that the board charges
and how much what the expenses are of
the office
could you uh give any highlights on that
so i don't know where a midwifery
council is at at this point i would say
they're probably under 100 that's just
off the top of my head they did have a
statutory fee of 110 so we were not able
to make any changes to that up until
recently and i don't know that the
governor has signed senate bill 313 but
if he does sign senate bill 313 that
would remove that statutory fee and we
would then
be in a position to promulgate rules
regarding fees
that said i have been advised not to do
anything regarding fees at this time
other than make you know keep things
consistent because there were some
not midwifery related stakeholders who
were extremely concerned about oplc's
ability to set fees
and
i was directed not to do anything
regarding fees until such time as
stakeholders can reach consensus on that
issue through senate bill 313 which is
kind of converted into senate bill 330.
other questions
well um seeing none then i think we'll
just move on to a committee discussion
and um
i'll express my opinion first if if
that's not objectionable
um
the original bill i think intentionally
or not was um
a little too aggressive and that's what
caused the
i don't want to call it enough roar but
the push back
my inclination is
it seems like uh it would be reasonable
to recommend
that legislation be considered in the
next cycle of course that's almost
a non-recommendation because as
representative schmidt pointed out
representatives are free to propose
legislation regardless of any
recommendation or not
but it seems that using the amended
version of this bill as a framework to
begin with
it would be a reasonable recommendation
that it should be pursued
and i would like to ask for a committee
member's
input on that suggestion
representative mcguire
yes thank you i mean i i agree with you
that there's
there are some things that need to be
changed in the statute and to
basically to recognize the existence of
the oplc and how the how the council
will work with it
and that's as representative schmidt
says we haven't worked out the details
by any means but it does seem like
something that
needs to be done
and we since we've been thinking about
it we should get to it before we forget
representative senator anastasia did you
have a comment
uh yeah i basically agree that we should
uh introduce legislation based on the
amended version uh there's a few changes
that need to be made and
not exactly sure how to
uh
do it at this time but uh we can
probably figure it out over the next
session
thank you representative sherwood
thank you i'm just uh expressing that i
hope that um
ms courtney and miss stevens will
continue their collaboration
and
perhaps come to us with some agreements
that we can incorporate into legislation
between all of us
that are here uh some of us should be
re-elected and please don't hesitate to
approach us
uh with whatever uh agreements you can
come up with that we can incorporate
and representative schmidt i saw you
nodding but would you like to add some
words
well i'm not on the subcommittee so i i
don't have a vote but but i'm pleased
with the direction that everybody is
going in that that we're going to try
and
do what's important for the people of
new hampshire and the practice of
midwifery so i'm i'm very pleased uh at
the direction you're headed thank you
so um correct me if i'm mistaken but it
seems to me that the recommendation of
this subcommittee is unanimously to
recommend future legislation on this
topic does anybody disagree with that or
want to modify that statement
and if not
i'll ask for a final comment from any of
the committee members
and if
there is none then i'll
adjourn this
all right thank you
well uh
carol do we have do we have a formal
vote here or is it more like a regular
subcommittee meeting it's
we could take a formal vote but the full
committee needs to vote on it on the
recommendation so you don't have to if
you don't want to okay well it's on the
record that this subcommittee was
unanimous and that's what we'll convey
to the full edna committee
all right thank you
all right we'll close this session
you